For the squamous cell cancer, what is the best scan to follow up with to gauge progress?
You really want to do scans based upon what was done before.
So you want to compare apples to apples.
So that's how you did an MRI before, and you want to see progress, do another MRI, or was
it a CT?
And that's what they showed the size itself, you do another CT.
But the question really is, why, you know, unless you're going to do a medical procedure
that, you know, they're going to recommend, you know, and I'm not saying you shouldn't.
But if you're considering doing radiation or chemotherapy, then by all means, you know, best
to compare apples to apples, best to compare the study that showed the size of diagnosed
the size and measurement of it before, to see if you're only doing this for curiosity
sake, I, you have to ask yourself the question, why?
Because there is in race and this to an MRI, there's certainly more in base of this to
a CT scan with the radiation, but there's still a base of this within MRI.
So I would, you know, if you swallow it better, what you're saying, then I would say continue
your role that you're going right now, unless you're considering doing some sort of other
standards of care.